Film Courage: How did you know the story [THE
VANISHING OF SIDNEY HALL] was special or maybe
you didn’t?
Shawn Christensen, Co-Writer/Director: I didn’t.
We felt it was special because…I don’t
know because when you write a screenplay I
think you think it’s special.
Whether or not it is special is kind of up
to the…you know…Lords of the Future.
But we thought it was special…I guess because
we enjoyed writing with each other and we
enjoyed the story we had built and we had
some good plot twists and we liked the non-linear
structure and we had written…Jason [Dolan]
had written four, five or six screenplays
at that point and I had written two.
And so when you get to your third script (your
third feature script), trust me you’ve learned
a lot.
And I think us teaming up and his weaknesses
and strengths and my weaknesses and strengths
really worked well together.
He’s very good at things that I’m not
and vice versa and so we liked it and we gave
it to ten of our friends.
Here’s something that I would advise any
screenwriter to do who is starting out.
You have a screenplay.
Don’t send the PDF to a person and ask them
to read it.
It’s just…you’re never going to get
anything with that.
What you have to do is you have to make it
a special thing.
What we did was we took ten friends, some
in the industry, some not (we didn’t know
many in the industry).
But friends that we trusted and thought they
were smart.
And we said we have a hardcopy of a screenplay.
We’d like you to come over to…(we had
an office that my co-writer was working for
someone with an office in Manhattan) and we
would like you to come over to the office
if you wouldn’t mind.
We’re not going to stand over you like a
funny farm and watch you read the pages or
whatever.
But we’d like you to read it and we’ll
walk away, we’ll be gone for a couple of
hours.
You can write notes, whatever.
You can bash it, we don’t care.
We just want like ten different peoples points-of-view.
So that’s what we did.
We had ten people read it.
Like they couldn’t leave with it, they couldn’t
take it, that way we know they’re going
to read it.
And we’re not going to stand over their
shoulder and then we left the office and came
back and then we sit down with them and talk
it out with them.
We took all of their notes.
We decided what we were feeling and sort of
where the consensus notes were and then we
went right back to it and then two weeks later
we had a script that we felt perhaps could
be given to people of note.
Film Courage: So you felt that in giving a
PDF that is would just sit inbox and they
would maybe find a reason to say “Oh, you
know what?
I’m so sorry, I’m really busy.”
But by having them there, sitting them down
with uninterrupted time, it was just a better
way to actually do it?
Shawn Christensen: You know, listen…that’s
a fact.
Think about it in terms of being on the other
side of the coin.
If your friend sends a PDF (a hundred-page
PDF) of something.
And maybe, by the way, you’re not a screenwriter,
you’re like their friend, you don’t really
read screenplays a lot.
It’s a daunting task.
It’s a task that…I don’t know how to
explain it.
You could be excited about reading a screenplay
that comes into your inbox, but generally
speaking in the age we live in with emails
and social media and all of these things for
people to get distracted by, to read your
friend or your cousin’s or your second cousin’s
or your friend’s brother’s uncle’s screenplay
or whatever, we felt that no one is going
to read our script if we just send them a
PDF of it.
Let’s just set a time for them to read it,
not be in the room when they read it but that
way they’ll read it and then right after
they read it we get their fresh, unfiltered,
you know…like feelings about the screenplay.
And then if we see things from like six out
of the ten of them are saying this is no good,
well then we know (that this is something
we’ve got to work on).